members if you could settle down please
the public my apologies for slightly
late start play it it's a slight overrun
in our training session but uh
hopefully we will be pleased with the
results at the end of the day with an
informed group of
members um okay
I have to read the evacuation
announcement which uh cannot see on
the um well I'll I an impromptu you one
in that case then um for those of you
that are not famili
um there is uh probably an
unlikely emergency evacuation but if we
do it has to be to the main col
Park this exit or the exit behind the
public part of the gallery um and meet
as I say in the main top
par
right
um I think that's probably CL it this is
uh a quazar Judicial meeting and we do
not allow smoking in public places
obviously can't
think that seems to be it right um to
the agenda then um apologies for absence
I have one for counselor yanu um I don't
think there there are any others from
theck
C and uh no substitute member for
councel
Al no members
attending yes
chairman councilor Wilkins and councelor
marol
madx minutes of the meeting held on the
10th of December 2015 are MERS in
agreement that they be
accepted thank
you and Declarations of
Interest I see no
indications sorry yeah just I'm a member
of R Town Council but I take no part in
any other can you put your sorry yes
chairman I'm a member of R Town Council
but take no part in any other plan
what chairman if I just to be clear that
would be thank you um chairman if I also
um may ask the nonmembers attaining
council matters and Council to declare
whether they have any
interest we can't hear
here ju just to clarify
sorry just to
clarify um I've asked nonmembers
attending just to confirm whether they
have any Declarations of interest and
they both confirm that there are none
from
there chairman I know it's not on the
agenda but just to advise through you if
I may I think you're obliged to say that
this meeting is not
recorded very correct yes I knew there
was something that was
left unfortunately that notice is is a
good checklist it's missing
um right um there been no
other
just um yes the only other thing was do
not delay to collect any belongings we
not I'm not aware of any um evacuation
or emergency test but so it'll be for
real don't hang
around
yes thank you my only interest in this
is W Council put on Chase
min Mr chairman can I ask a question on
that as um councelor MX is the war
counselor he has the right to ask
questions but he can't vote is that
correct that's correct thank you very
much right um item six um the pon Chase
Nursery fully know poly to consider a
planning application for the erection of
70 dwellings together with improvements
to existing access pedestrian access car
parking Landscaping open space and
related
Works can I just um we're doing
presentations now for all um
applications so if you look up there is
the presentation set up which um we'll
actually talk you
through chairman this is an application
of Pon Chase Nursery
poan as you can see here this is a site
location so it's an irregular shap
shaped site and we've got in a southern
area um the main access road coming into
the site which leads through to one
individual dwelling here some commercial
buildings which and this area is all
predominantly hard standing apart from
this area at the front where we have
some soft land Landscaping
present to the rear here the Northern
Area is where we have a soft landscape
area which is predominantly ponds and
grass that particular section we also
have ditches located to the East and the
West there are three designations for
the site we have residential Frontier
and then to the center is allocated by
policy sdr3 for 50 dwellings and then to
the rear here we've got the green
belt
this AAL photograph just gives a bit of
perspective to the site so we've got the
railway lines in the north here in an
area of Woodland we also got
residentials surrounding the site in
particular we've got the AAS which was
underway at the time this this are which
was taken um we've also granted Planning
Commission outline Planning Commission
for seven dwellings within this location
here which also forms part of the
allocated
site
so here we have the proposed layout so
we're looking at scheme for 70 dwellings
a mixture of dwelling types from one to
five bedroom we have one main access
into the site here going around into a a
loop road Arrangement and then we have a
Home Zone area here which will be a
private private
road there is an area of play in this
location here we would have public open
space towards the northern area of the
site here there's a foot path which
would be link directly to fly Lane in
this location and then here we would
have a footpath and cycle link which
would go through the other allocated s
to Church
Road so the these images just help to
give a bit of a an idea of the street
seem that we be looking at so this top
one here is the entrance way into the
site looking on the right hand side so
we have terorist units this particular
location and then at the bottom here
this would be the area of the site
looking out towards the open space to
the north where we've predominantly
detached unit
just gives a bit of an idea of the type
of house types the we be looking at most
of the houses are two or two and a half
story and there a few three story
present as
well again this is just gives an
indication of um perspective drawings of
what the development would look like so
at the top here this is the entrance way
through we got those terorist units
again there a attached unit of the end
and there the area of play would be just
top around here and this would be the
Home Zone in the center of the so a
slightly different character um with a
different appearance to the road type in
that
location so the site is allocated for 50
dwellings by
policy3 and in 2012 councils agreed to
50 through a committee meeting for an
outline planning application the
application proposal together with the
land south of Winfield site where we'
granted permission for the seven
dwellings would result in 75 dwellings
within the allocated site officers
consider that policy SE three should not
be applied too stringently and that the
number increase would be acceptable as
long as the design is to a good standard
which is considered to be the case
here the density proposes 34 dings per
hectare which is considered acceptable
aspite a variety of density in the local
area and dm2 policy D2 seeks a minimum
of 30 dings per hectare the county Urban
Design officer does not object to design
to some conditions to seek Min
improvements The Proposal is policy
compliant in respect Garden sizes
parking and the technical hous standards
and refuse arrangements are considered
acceptable with a strategy plan provided
showing where being would be stored and
presented off flection day and showing
the ability for a ref vehicle to
maneuver around the
site impact on neighboring properties so
the most affected those funing poly Lan
so particularly number 727 8 and 82 and
also properties location aers the new
development access of the Church Road
it's not considered the development be
detrimental to be occupies these
properties in terms of scout or
overlooking there is a condition that
could be imposed to address any
potential window overlooking from this
development the S is like cased within
flood zone one and a critical drainage
area the proposed surface water drainage
arrangement for the site includes sewers
which would then connect through to two
detention Basin here they would then
drain through to this this existing Pond
here and then they would pascade down to
an existing ditch that's where they
would out for there also some would also
drain through to this existing ditch the
bottom here which would then come
through
here County Council have no objection to
uh the proposed SE to drainage
Arrangements they do suggest conditions
particularly with regards to maintenance
now with with regards to maintenance
it's important to note that The Home
Zone area so that area I highlighted
earlier this particular section here
that would be private County highways
would adopt the drainage within the
adoptable highway so the remainder of
the site but the drainage and roadway
within the Home Zone would be the
responsibility of their management
company concern has been raised with
regard to if the management company were
to fold who would the responsibility of
the maintenance fall to the finite
wording of the legal agreement would
ensure there remains someone responsible
for maintenance whether it would be the
existing land owner if they retained
ownership on contract work out to a
maintenance company of folded or a new
land
owner so with this this plan here we're
showing that we got the the the play
Space located here which is proposed and
the open space to the north this sizing
meets policy se3 for a 50 ring scheme
but the open space sizing requires a
proportionate increase to reflect the
greater number of wedings from po which
consider to be adequately dealt with by
condition and outdoor sport of Youth
facility and allotments are also
requireed on policy3 there was capacity
for these to be accommodated Northern in
that Northern area again and controlled
by condition just to point out as well
this Northern Area is actually much
larger than it's shown on this
particular layout plan this is more
indan version to accommodate
that the societ is consider to be
located within a sustainable location
County Harvest have no objection to the
use of the site and the existing access
by 70 dwellings they do suggest
conditions for example visibility displ
in the upgrading of the orman's Hill bus
stop with regards to
ecology there are three badg sets on or
AG the site one of those sets would be
closed to Ena development there's also
been slow worms and grass snakes
discovered during survey work however
the council's ecologist is not
considered there to be um any objection
to the development and consider
mitigation could be sufficiently dealt
with by
fici during the course of the
application a treaty preservation order
was issued which predominantly covered
areas of the eastern and the northern
elements of the site some works of POS
reservor quite minor works the C tree
offer does not object to those
works the phase two assessment submitted
has confirm contamination is present on
the site but conditions could ensure
that such contamination is sufficiently
addressed
whilst no lightting scheme submitted
with the application such a scheme could
be sufficiently required by condition
and we have dealt with that in that
manner previously with scheme such as
this no air quality or night assessments
have submitted with the application
however the air quality assessment um is
only required in relation to transport
movements the transport assessment
confirms there be no increase in traffic
movements compared to the authorized
usage and therefore a quality is not
likely to differ at the site a
requirement for a dust management scheme
and will washing facilities by condition
would address air quality during
construction work
phases with r noise it is considered
that the noise Genera from the site will
be less than the authorized commercial
operation renewable energy The Proposal
is for Sol photo panels but the more
detail around that could be dealt with
by a condition in regards to Health Care
uh it has been identified as a deficit
with regards to local doctor surgeries
of around
£23,000 such mitigation has been
accepted by the developer and and will
be paid and funded through the legal
agreement
process with regards to affordable
housing the quantity proposed meets
policy we have 25 units at
35.7% we also have Acceptance Now of the
10 year mix of 8020 although we would
have potential for variation subject to
the viability or need statement with
regards to education there is not
sufficient cap capacity at Primary
School level however the ACT has agreed
to fund this deficit which is amount to
around
£26,000 um sought by ESS County Council
now these were the only two outstanding
M matters identified by officers which
had resulted in the recommendation for
accusal that you would have seen
initially presented so the
recommendation has now been revised from
that presented with the with the initial
recommendation to refuse refusal to
approval subject to a legal agreement
and planning conditions are set out
within the
agenda
thank
you right um we have uh two speakers um
speaker one is Mr T dodkins planning
agent for Charles Church if you'd like
to come forward please we'll try and
time you for 5 minutes from the start of
your
presentation and I'll give
you notice of one minute to
go thank you
chair I think many of the issues I was
going to discuss been been covered by
the officers hopefully I can be brief
something less than 5 minutes chairman
we're having difficulty hearing over
again can we can we turn
this thing on because that's so loud
have to stop
ch
thank
you sorry about that if youd like to
begin again that's okay problem
application before you for the
Redevelopment of a brown for site
allocated in the core strategy and as
many members will recall um part of that
strategy or part of the policy approach
of the cor strategy was to try and bring
forward the development of Brownfield
sites where possible before Greenfield
sites the site received resolutions
Grant outline Planning Commission as you
heard for the construction of 50 houses
some years ago this application seeks to
deliver 70 new houses ensuring that this
previously developed land is used
efficiently also retaining and enhancing
green spaces and matrial
trees in particular as you've heard from
officers all relevant rord District
Council space standards are
achieved the proposals include 70 new
homes all designed to a high quality
standard and in keeping with the local
context as you've heard 35% of the homes
were designated for affordable housing
with the uh with 80% for affordable
rents and 20% for intermediate tenure
which as you've heard is is in full
accordance with Council
policy the affordable homes have been
designed to be 10e blind which basically
means that they use the same high
quality materials um that are used to
construct both the private and the
affordable
homes as you've also heard the proposed
section 106 contributions for local
infrastructure include £26,000 for
education £3,000 for healthare and these
amounts are are in line with those
requested by the relevant statutory
bodies Charles Church is committed to
returning and enhancing the green space
in the Northern parts of the site as
you've seen as well as existing mature
trees in total Al that wasn't clearly
shown on the plan but one3 of the site
is reserved for the provision of public
open space plans also include a focal
square and a play area and as you've
also heard sustainable Drainage Systems
will will be implemented as part of the
development and a flood risk assessment
that's has been supplied with the
application has concluded that
development would not increase the
chance of flooding on this site or in
the surrounding
area careful attention has been paid by
the applicants to both parking and
access Arrangements the existing access
to the site from Folly Lane will be
enhanced with measures to improve
visibility and reduce traffic speeds
throughout the development the new homes
will have allocated parking spaces
either on FL or through carport links
with further spaces available to
visitors the parking we're proposing
meets All County uh parking
standards local residents had the
opportunity to provide valued feedback
on the plans through a program of
consultation that included an exhibition
at the old far station in hotley last
June and we were encouraged to receive a
number of positive comments from local
residents um including one resident from
Ching Gardens who lived in hotley for
over 32 years and advises that you
strugging to by a home on the private
market and was quite Keen to uh discuss
the uh units um that were proposed for
intermediate
tenue in addition to Consulting
residents Charles Church has worked hard
to encourage engage relevant
stakeholders and has taken time to
resolve all issues raised by officers
both before and after the submission of
the
application there are no outstanding
technical objections and the application
has received support as you've heard
from ess's County Council and design
team the sole issue that remained was of
obligations as set out in the main
committee report and that's now been
resolved officers have as you've seen
issued an addendum report which updates
the officer recommendations reflect the
remaining issues address and as such the
application is recommended for approval
we hope that you will agree and result
to approve spr development that will
deliver much needed high quality homes
on this side thank
you thank you
um our second speaker is Mr G Crocket an
objector from FY L you like come
forward you also have five minutes with
a one minute REM to to finish thank you
ch
um my name is gr Propet I've lived in
Folly Lane for over 20 years now and
I've lived in the ray holey area just
about all my life I care deeply about
the area and that is why I'm here to
talk to you today I noticed my previous
speaker was calling the area
Brownfield but it wasn't Brownfield was
it it was green bille the only reason
that it has become Brownfield is because
if you don't mind me saying the
incompetence of the council
any of you who don't remember I will
take you back and remind you exactly
what has happened over the
years if the council had stopped the
mushroom farm being extended Beyond
reasonable
use and then not lost an unlosable court
case we would never have a Brownfield
site there
now if four years ago the council hadn't
been persuaded to make it an industrial
area it wouldn't be Brownfield it would
still be green
bille
Traffic I think you need to look at the
bigger picture you have Hall Road
thousands of houses being built and raw
Lan proposal for thousands of
houses I don't know if the members have
been able to get down to the junction of
the a130 a127 or the
a1245 at Russia if you're coming from
London
down the a127 now the road is crawling
all the way
through if you go from chelsford to down
to 130 to the roundabout which you turn
right to go to
cany there's a mile tail back every
single day we we are proposing to build
thousands of houses in this area we
can't take any
more we've noticed already that F Lane
is becoming a rat
one
if you're coming from chood and you know
about the a13 a127 junction you try and
miss it
out you come off at Baton bridge and at
the moment you go up Ro and through Ro
and through ra and up that
way that IND if that new estate is
building Ro people aren't going to do
that they're going to go down watery
Lane they're going to go through hridge
they're going to go down lower Road and
they're going to continue coming down
Folly Lane we can't take
anymore trains I have the pleasure of
traveling out to London every day the
train companies have tried to increase
capacity there are 12 coaches to each
train now there are more trains now than
there's ever been before all this has
done is mean that I've been traveling
for 30 years the trains are slower now
than they have ever been
before all these people who you are
proposing to build houses for either
going to be driving or they're going to
be traveling via train it used to be
that you go to shenfield you might not
get a seat now it's
wiford 7 new homes does sound like a
great deal down Folly Lane but this is a
Country Lane people are already parking
on the
road every house has two
cars doctors I noticed the 23,000
payment that's been
offered it's pathetic isn't it my wife
had to try and get a doctor's
appointment this week funny enough rang
up on Monday 3 weeks she was told it was
going to
take only alternative was to go down
before 8:00 today to get an appointment
in the Freez in Cen Q up there so she
did that she was so Keen to get a
doctor's appointment she got down there
first in the queue got to the
receptionist no
appointments
23,000 that might pay a GP for one year
what happens after that
it makes no
sense you have one minute thank you very
much um I've nearly finished I'd like to
thank you for paying attention to what
I've had to say I appreciate that my
arguments are arguments that you
probably have all heard
before but they the reason you've heard
them before because they're important
arguments to people in the local area
I'd like to think that if people
felt that what they said at a meeting
like this would be taken note of that
there will be more people here in
objection I think the fact that they're
on says an awful lot we know that there
are cuts from central government that
you have to take into
consideration but it's about time I
think the council started to look after
the people that voted them
in rather than central
government dictating to you what you
should be doing
I'd like to thank you all for giving me
the time and I'd like to oppose that you
this than
you do officers wish to reply to any of
the matters raised
there me just just quickly I mean the
principle of the development here was
set out clearly in the Cy and that went
to a corre process um so in terms of the
s's allocation as far as the's um point
of view is the fact that the site is
allocated residential and um that is the
principle was clearly set out so um that
is what we have to work with um in
regard to this right um I have a number
of indications
um I'm not sure who was actually first
on on this Council SE okay thank thank
you chairman I'd just like some points
of clarification please um do you want
I've got a number of questions do you
want me to list the questions and then
officers come back or would you how do
you want to do
it
sorry yeah if you like
toist first of all uh looking at the
drawing that is on the screen currently
uh the road going around the site looks
very much like a good racetrack to me uh
I'd like i' like to know what um things
are going to be put in place to stop
that being used as somewhat of a uh a
mini
circuit uh the officers mentioned sewers
running into the U ponds CL can you
clarify that I suspect they probably
mean the rain water run off rather than
the sewers but please we have a
planification on that the roads
themselves will they be
adopted um I suspect the one in the
middle going across site is probably not
going to be adopted but I'm not sure
about the others um if they're not
adopted will they be up to the standard
to take our waste trucks which go some
17 18 19
tons finally in the notes there's
reference to uh trees particularly uh
silver birch
trees um whilst I uh fully endorse the
um communication with regards to certain
people having allergies to them like a
couple points of
clation will that set a president for
other sites as to what sort of
landscaping will be in and what would
happen in the case of a resident who B
bu one of the properties wishes to put
in a silver birch tree into their house
will there therefore be will we be
placing Covance on the properties to
stop that from happening it seems a
little bit of an opening request thanks
J um I can do those points quickly
actually um I mean the um because
obviously the matter we had to change
the following the change in terms of
contributions um we have an application
that for refusal and obviously addendum
sets out the um the recommendation areas
for um for approval um and there are set
there sets within that the conditions
and one of those conditions that we we
are suggesting relates to the road
layout and we can deal with a traffic
caling traffic calming methods within
that as part of that condition um in
terms of SE that correct great that's
that's the rain water sustainable Urban
drainage system and OB that would be
rain water um in terms of the um the
roads will be adoptable apart from the
part which um which CLA made out through
the Home Zone bit which will not be um
adopted um and that will be um of a
adoptable standard but not adopted by I
think because it doesn't quite meet the
um the road the road size that actually
adoptable Landscaping you're quite right
um a condition we cannot control
landscaping and we cannot control how
people how what people do with that with
their with that with with their schemes
um it it is it is an impossible quest
for any local authority to put a
restricted Covenant or condition we
couldn't put a covenant on anyway deals
with that so in real terms um we
couldn't we couldn't we can suggest that
they make considerations but we cannot
actually say you can't use bachula as a
as a species with within within a um
schem because they are quite robust
trees and actually their trees that tend
to tend to look nice quite quickly and
they and you get Form and Function quite
in the development I hope that s your
question thank you um Council
hater uh Mr chairman I'm concerned that
this development which amounts to 75
homes in all is 70 in this development
will be a 50% increase in the
development inv vised by the core
strategy I'm very concerned the lack of
road infrastructure for this devopment
now Folly Lane is a twisting narrow
Country Lane with just over 80 houses
Fountain Lane is a narrow oneway Lane
leading to the hotley road with no foot
path the hotley road is frequently
gridlocked from hambro Hill to spar Road
Junctions of Holly Lane and Fon Lane
with Hawley Road are difficult and
dangerous Church Road is a narrow Lane
leading to Lower Road which is is
frequently gridlocked through holbridge
and onto
raain in addition Mr chairman fly Lane
has parking problems s gate B and
Hawthorne Gars to be introduced into
this traffic stalemate is 70 new homes
with a potential of 200 Cars I feel this
is over development put in a court into
a pint pot yes it's County counts of
Highways as usual make makes no com on
this lack of road infrastructure their
world is different from l or of that of
many residents of Hoy and bra highways
in particular never deal with chaos that
the communative effect of developments
will have on our roads such as
developments in Hall Road Clemens Main
Road H braan West Road PL hallbridge and
l Road
breake Mr chairman it is with regret I'm
of the view that this is not planning
but Chaos on our roads to be visited on
our children and grandchildren my last
point is this that uh what that
gentleman said said about the doctor's
situation the medical situation I I
completely concur with 23,000 is is
nothing at all so I'm not happy with
this uh with this development at all
sh than you
c yeah thank you Mr chair
um I've got a couple of I
begin question first The Home Zone if I
understand um
a director um it's not the size of the
loan is not to an adoptable standard is
that because it's too narrow or is it
too short why could it not be
adopted the um the road it is partly to
do with sides part shared surface um and
that basically changes the um how that
that part of the development is actually
seen as a like a CALA area in terms of
the fact that it's not it doesn't form
part of a normal Form and Function it's
like a private a private roadway and a
lot of developments do have do have that
that approach now where you've got a
different a different surfacing um and
it creates a um a break between um to
out housing within that area if if I
think if you look at how the the site is
formed the the break in the development
there um creates a situation where you
don't end up with a with a with a a a
further a further wrapped run where the
where the traffic could come around that
site and cause I think cause more
problems The Home Zone is is has come
forward from the um the the applicant as
far as we're concerned it's um it's
acceptable in terms of it um how it sits
within the development site and it's not
a um it doesn't cause any problem in
terms of um of any other issues with
regards to the um the surface or the
road
size come back
um seeing the the I think the design of
the of The Home Zone it seem to be quite
an enclosed area not very much an Urban
Design rather the rural design and I'm
thinking back to my early days of the
ess6 design guide 1984 talk about rural
Arcadia and the built Urban environment
and and The Home Zone seems to be much
more of a built Urban environment than
than anything else certainly not R
Arcadia
um the and I concerned because because
is not being adopted by the County
Highway
the the the drainage isn't beinged
County
highways being aded either you've got
problems so he said it's going to be
under the managed by somebody else
and that's fine um having spent a fair
bit of last Sunday talking to a lawyer
who just moved on to ro of flan near
near the glass ver by the burden way and
trying to explain the him why it wasn't
who who owned it and why it wasn't
maintained properly why it was more dead
very buy up under the
bridge the these little areas of
grassland or drainage but not being put
under somebody's under statutary or
authority or similar bodies management
worry me CU they end up with all these
bodies these private companies they go
bus and it's very hard um to keep track
of them so if the C does go B in 25
years who's going to pick up the PES in
how soon you know it is and if it's not
maintained who who do they serve you
know that is it that a side issue my
main concern is still about the housing
but we have 50 was passed in the course
strategy um I I voted against that in
the
minority um however if the Quant been 75
there might been a few more voting
against it you know it is a 50% increase
on what was course strategy um I would
not like to see 50% replicate anywhere
else in the
district the offices report do do give
some kind of justification for allowing
to going over that figure it still seems
to be too high and I'm finding extremely
hard to support this application tonight
because it is I believe is contrary to
our strategy um I I that's my case here
but if it's nobody I'm considering
moving refusal but I see what happens in
the meeting thank you thank you yes
Mrs thank you very much Mr chairman Mr
chairman I have several things i' like
to say in the beginning there has been a
nursery there which didn't grow
mushrooms which grew tomatoes and I as a
young teenager worked there in
1948 so please don't tell me that site
has been um hasn't been used for
industrial Reasons from a long long time
and I'm an old lady and I remember
working there so that's one thing it was
tomato in those days but my main concern
is that this site and how this layout is
is very very similar to the bra Lane
development uh in which comes under
Counsel cutmore on myself either side
that's not me and the other side of the
road to you and it just has although it
has a scool and everything else on it it
just has the one road coming out and and
it's a similar layout and it is working
extremely well it also does have a very
nice Pond which is for the flooding and
again that is everybody is very
surprised and pleased with it but my two
things two other things one the foot
pass through and I don't know what thaty
B places are called M but is the foot
path through this estate does that go
into Church Road
there
officers yes it would go through the the
development which is just in the Au
which is still um believe it's unless
it's been sold to somebody else um it
will connect up with that so because
it's only granted outline permission at
the moment we could still deal with the
full detail around how it would connect
fully through the church in the future
that's the intention well about that
foot path it does then enable people
that want to go Etc and to go down
Church Road and under the railway region
and go out that way that's one thing I
want to ask I also want to know um you
talked about allotments am I writing
thinking in the green belt situation
there would it be possible in the future
for maybe H not hwk HW Parish Council to
lease an area of that land for
allotments for people to you in the
hotley parish area I'm sorry I'm not
hotley Parish counselor but I do know
that people do want allotments and if it
was possible and it could be le on a
long term but allotments that the parish
council would maintain I think that
would be a very good idea but again that
comes under things later on um but
basically um looking at it and seeing
it's another area and it's finishing off
of an area of our district where a nice
little development and again I go back
to the brace Lane development and to see
that and also another development in
Council cm's area um up off with can
Road can view and there the little um
the Nelson Road and that bit there
there're small developments that finish
off our major areas of development and I
personally think a lot of work work has
gone in since we all kicked up and we've
had our questions and I and I I I'm one
of those that I'm in favor of it and if
needs be I will put a proposal up that
we Grant it if I have the session thank
you thank you um I think officers may be
able to give advice on that I suspect
that that may not be a planning
consideration for this application can I
um I just come back on the issue of the
um allotments there is a condition um
outlined um at condition 46
um to um obvious for the allotments and
obviously we can discuss the legal
outside planning process with regards to
how those are going to be um allotted
and who who maintains them and obviously
that could be an issue that we could
discuss with ho par
Council and I put You'
already that will whatever happens that
will come into
as so again there is conditions attached
for the um the rights of way of the
sites and obviously that would be
something that the developer have to
have to um show indicative on a on a
plan and may I just briefly come back
with one other subject to do with that
and that is the ponds that are going to
be there will they be deep enough and
will people be able to fishing them
thank
you um at this stage I can't comment on
the depth of those BS I'm really
sorry right um counselor Mr
Mason
thank you chairman um like counc step
Ratt off a couple of questions and then
I've got a couple things on the say so
I'll Ratt off the questions and officers
can answer at the the end of what I've
got to say um the question is could the
officers please point out to me where
the affordable houses are on the plan
that's on the screen in the second
instance I would like to know whether
each property has uh its own allocation
of imunity space to the standards that
we've laid down or are they using space
elsewhere in
site and in terms of comments um we've
have a presentation we've had Council ha
to speak about highways but um I think
it behoves us to say that um we we are
entirely dependent on the traffic
studies done by the um by the African
the traffic study assessments that are
done by the County Council and whilst we
may have personal views on whether or
not um the right um understanding has
been reached in the report sadly there's
nothing we can do about it and um if we
could end up in a situation where were
we to turn down an application for high
waste matters we could find ourselves
potentially available for significant
costs because we don't have the
expertise to determine that um the
second one is a response if you like to
uh councelor black who spoke about the
quantum I certainly understand his point
about the quantum but I need to tell him
that at the public examination on the
elocation sites the dear inspector
decided to delete our cap of 5% increase
so any site across the District Council
of black can be increased to at least 30
and it will have to be increased to at
least 30 because there that is our our
standard and anywhere beyond that I'd
just like to have answers to those
questions please chairman thank you
councelor Mrs
Mason are
you
m counc Mason did indicate that he would
be waiting for um replies at the Finish
but if it's more conveni I think was
after I fin speak um the social housing
is marked in green on the plan in front
of
you can I come back on that particular
Point certainly chairman I don't know
whether this is a policy because I
haven't read the development management
policy recently but in every other um
application we've looked at and indeed
we've passed we've insisted on pepper
potting that's not pepper potting so um
I would like to ask the offices whether
that complies with the council policies
and why it doesn't comply with the
Precedence we previously
said I mean for this kind of development
this is official peer potting
acceptability um we're not looking at a
large scale development we're looking at
a medium scale development and this
meets the requirement for for that to um
to
occur I don't believe that makes our
policies thank you um I I a wait the
answers on immunity space
please
yeah in terms of Amen SP set report at
paragraph 60 um 6.21 and 6.22 that the
um all of all of the um properties um U
meet the minimum standards within within
their own
plots um and the final point in terms of
the um eics highways and um we as Lo
plan authorties and Ro District Council
aren't the highway Authority the highway
Authority sits outside on control um it
sits within County Council they are the
highway Authority um we have to seek
their um their considerations for
developments um if we considered that it
was um an incorrect response then we
would ourselves be open for a challenge
and you're quite right um so in in real
terms if if um if they consider the
application with their own work and the
work of the applicant to be acceptable
then that is the position that that that
we have to that we are left with um as
we are not a unitary Authority we have
no no no control un authori is obviously
different a different position um so as
far as we're concerned inv County
Council accept the development um in
terms of it what it will what will fall
from it um there are number of
conditions that they've come forward
with and again those are set out in in a
um in a format in the um in addendum um
and obviously we will be building on
these um to work into full
C Mrs
Mason thank you Mr
chairman firstly can I say I have
sympathy and empathy with the problems
outlined by the speaker however as my
co- Council has clearly demonstrated and
said our hands are tied M County Council
in those respects especially in respect
of
Transport I'm also concerned with some
other aspects of the property I'm
certainly concerned with the lack of
pepper potting for the affordable
housing I'm not sure where the amenity
space is for the plants but that's a
minor point there the more I have heard
about this application the less I'm I'm
liking it however the one thing that we
do need in this area is affordable
housing and members are generally
rightly concerned about the provision of
affordable housing or the lack of it
especially for the rented sector indeed
in the report that we have before over
applicants asking for properties rented
properties in hoty alone the officer's
report highlight this need and I would
have hoped the viability assessment
would have been provided by the
applicant before the application was put
before this development
committee I do feel strongly that
members should have the final say on
affordable housing provision and do not
feel this should be delegated to
officers may I ask that if we can if we
do approve this
application that we Al to the condition
condition under recommendation condition
one in line with the president set in
the Hall Road development committee
decision in that any variation from our
policy of 80 to 20 is referred back to
the full development committee and not
authorized by officers thank you
Council makes s a very good point and we
would agree with that that that is the
correct way forward um the um the any
viability assessment that would that
would move away from that 8020 we fought
hard to get that 8020 um and I tell you
that we will bring that back to
committee if there's any variation that
with a full viability report or needs
assessment because obviously the
council's requirement is to provide
rented properties um there is um the
amount of need there was for um
intermediate housing is very low and
that's why we pushed um the application
was orig for refusal um based on that
information so in real terms you are
quite correct there um that decision
will come back to this committee well
can I have that in the condition please
add and at the end and refer back to
development committee thank you we can
arrange for that thank you very
much Council
C thank you chairman couple of questions
I was going to ask have already been
asked and answered so that's that's good
and the only point I wanted to make was
that indeed this was an industrial site
and of course it would have traffic um
so there'll be existing traffic some of
which were large lores going forward and
I know that some of the more uh should
we say older members had been members
for a while um would have gone to site
visits down there and I think I went on
a couple of site visits down there uh
and of course there were many industrial
units all of them had traffic coming out
of them um and I think there were
objections at the time I think relating
to when when uh you know the the change
was made in some of the units uh when
they went from producing mushrooms as it
was to uh to the actual industrial units
but nevertheless the president was sent
then whether you agree with that or not
that's where we are so uh I don't
necessarily think that the extra traffic
that would be involed would actually be
extra traffic chairman uh yes there
would be cars I'm not sure about 200 uh
but uh I think somebody who has an
affordable home necessarily have three
cars but having said that chairman uh
you know I finally uh acceptable in
those terms and I think
the changes to display Etc would
actually accommodate some of that um
nevertheless we all love to use our cars
we're all the same so has to for that
not anybody else but nevertheless I do
recommend and I'd like to I think you
moved for approval didn't you yes I'd
like to second that
chair thank
you
um Council hater you've already spoken I
may come back to you for a brief
contribution but I would point out that
two other members have indicated
and a w counselor um will be wishing to
speak at the finish of these questions
or presentations I to speak
to thank you um I'm glad that I mean I
asked um CLA Buckley um the question uh
a couple of days back that that was
actually brought up by a couple of
members in regards to
uh the maintenance uh and how that was
going to take place and I know that
there is concern uh and I voice that
concern myself um where other
developments have have gone Ary because
the management company even G broke g
into
liquidation and um we were were looking
at the assurances that we would need to
extract to ensure that going forward
there were sufficient guarantees that
maintenance would continue
especially on the concerns with regards
to the draining system uh and all those
various things which would be a general
concern to I guess all the residents in
the area and surrounding residents so
you know I think that needs to be noted
and I know you took that on board and I
believe it but that's not a settled
issue at this moment I
believe it's certainly something that we
could do with in more finite detail in
the wording of the legal agreement with
our legal colleagues to make sure that
we can get SU in place on the site and
long term and longm thank you and and
can I just just one little question um
pedestrian access on the road um I I
believe the developer uh the agent
mentioned that um you know where that
access was going to go in it would be
sufficiently wide um has that got uh
payments at all I know it's got
obviously got vehicle access but are
there also Pavements for you know
pedestrians coming in and
out I it looks like there are but I just
want that
confirmed um yeah there is and obviously
um again we've got conditions again set
out here to ensure that all the state
roads and foot paths because obviously
are agreed at this moment is not
particularly we we've accept that as a
condition attached to the um the
Planning Commission that estate Road and
foot RADS um are to be fully with us so
we've got that as a
condition can
M thank you g um forgive me if um I
there is something in the conditions but
um the maintenance of the open space um
how is that going to be arranged is is
there some agreement on that is that
included in the section 106
agreement yes the the maintenance would
cover the open space and play Space
along with other aspects such as the
service drainage so they would be
covered as
one counc
hater yes thank you Mr chairman my only
point is this that um uh I know that
Council Mas said that the County Council
highways you can't challenge it well I
would dispute that because I think here
they have a duty to deal with access
they have a duty to deal with the
surrounding roads and here they have um
it's Prim F she failed to do so I don't
think there would be any problem if one
went on appeal to raise that they have
not referred to the surrounding roads at
all the state of traffic in the
surrounding roads they should do so and
they haven't done
so thank you Council hater I would
assure you that uh the best will in the
world I doubt that your expertise equals
that of the offices of
se6 Highways but uh I believe they do
consider such
matters uh councelor black wish you wish
to speak yes motion chairman um I was to
speak to the motion and to oppose it
um could I ask before the vote is taken
that page 50 page 50 of the allocations
document
please my iPad um it deals with this
site in West hland
um what looking for that I just say I
can't agree a counselor hater um I do
not think we going to on highways there
any chance of
success speaking of somebody with
experience of refusals and going to
appeal I'm sorry that's not that's it's
a all of the NADA I'm really sorry
I don't see it's not to succeed um I
I'll read it out um this is the document
is dealing with this site in Westley and
it says the site will accommodate no
more than 50 dwellings unless it can be
demonstrated that and there are two
Clauses there but the first one is the
additional number of dwellings are
required to maintain a 5year land Supply
now I know can yes it's come down there
there is it is yeah there is thank you
very much for that
um there may be arguments over before
months we've got a 5e year land Supply
but reading report at the moment we do
have and I don't think a case has been a
case has been made I don't think it's
been demonstrated that these 20 or so
extra houses here in West holey are
require ired to maintain a 5year land
Supply I can't support this application
for those reasons
alone
yeah thank
you do any other members wish to speak
before c St to yes chairman just a point
of clarification the uh social housing
we sping in centy terms can we have the
actual number they
are it's
right C MX as Ward member you've been
very patient in in in in waiting and I
hope that some of your um potential
questions might have been already
answered but please do absolutely
chairman and uh I thank the committee
for their observations and I'm so glad
that some of the members uh are uh
casting doubt on this application I
certainly agree uh I'm going to take
your guidance because I don't know what
I can say I know I can ask questions but
I don't know what I can say so I'll take
your guidance I certainly will agree I
certainly will agree with the speaker
the local resident and most of what he
said um the highways issue is horendous
um I reluctantly agreed with the uh 2012
50 houses because I thought that was
acceptable I don't agree with this one
but if members do um agree that this
goes through I've got one or two
questions and most have been answered
but I'll I'll try and think of some more
um your conditions planning conditions
how do you um hope have officers hope to
enforce
those conditions are are the conditions
are set out on any notice are
enforceable under our legislation and
they are enforced um and that's a point
which you know we are pushing forward as
a as as as a service now is full
compliance with conditions they should
be compli they will be complied with um
and on new developments such as this and
we're looking to build quality into our
developments they will be compli with um
otherwise it's it's pointless put in
adding them to a development and um I
mean I'm I'm M to Rochford I'm used to
developments complying with conditions
and if that means taking developers to
court I've taken developers to court I
I've taken developers to court and
almost um business so I'm you know I'm
quite happy to to move that forward so
in terms of this commission with or any
commission with attached to it they will
be we will see as same as one I I check
your observations and thank you for that
um if this application goes
through and I'm hoping it
doesn't um I'd like to refer to number
46 on those conditions is there a
location dedicated for that
now and on the plan could you show me
that please and the entrance exit so
that that's about the allotment I
apologize there's no allocated space as
as of yet it would be something that we
would agree by condition as to exactly
where would be the best location bear in
mind um preserve trees we have on the
site um and ecological consideration so
it's something that we would work to try
and get position as to where that could
be located okay thank you for that
obviously within with allotments show
Beal access yeah I'm hoping and can I
just say um holey has a list of 37
people that have been waiting probably
15 or 20 years for allotments and the
parish have failed them greatly but now
this is coming forward possibly if it's
pushed through um I'm hoping some of
those on that list would be accepted to
that site for allotments I don't know if
there's a condition that they can or
cannot I know Mrs Glen mentioned
something um as I as I raised before on
that point I said we would discuss Le up
how how we can how we can ensure that
they're managed correctly and whether or
not we can deal with poppy Parish
Council on that okay thank you just one
more if I may make an observation to
this committee and thank you for
listening um I would actually like if
you are going to put this through I'd
like condition on that that the
allotments are time span within six or
12 months after the full development uh
and uh conditions are complied with
thank
you I it what about the
allotments chairman if I may on the
allotments um if I recall allotments um
would need the cooperation of your
Parish Council to to to um assist with
us legally the Lots cannot be
transferred to the council then
transferred onto the parish council so
the parish council would be fully
involved in that on that point so then
once it's transferred it down to the
parish council to
manage if I may come
back thank
you I may say something that's wrong
sorry
legal
uh the gentleman that assist of running
of the parish council Michael I can't
remember his surname has been an anti of
opments ever since he got there so
whether he gets cooperation or not and
whether the actions of the parish
counselors have just been a matter of
course
toate um applicants for the allotments
that may never have uh come along I I'm
I'm doubtful that the parish council may
help
I'm concerned but I'm hoping that this
application is turned down
anyway okay I was just question if the
parish council aren't interested in
there is it possible to have another
lock organization to pick up where par
Cil I'm not sitting any other indication
so perhaps I'll use Chairman's
prerogative to ask a couple of questions
of my own um could you um officers
refresh my memory as to the actual
density um
requirements I believe it's uh normally
an excess of um 30 dwellings per hectare
and what is actually applicable to this
proposal this the site has 30 Bings per
hectare and the minimum by policy we
look for is 30 so this this is the
minimum which would be allow minimum is
30 so it
exceeds so so it's
quite the sorry can you just repeat the
actual density of this proposal is4 34
sorry I catch
before
right okay um so the benefit of the
public uh and for the um speaker I
believe there were some um slightly
erroneous figures mentioned also in
terms of U house uh building within
development within the district um Hall
Road was mentioned as being a
development of thousands um that is not
the
case that that may be the actual the
actual figure for the um annual
expectation within the period of the um
local development plan is a mere 250
houses per year which is a very small
number relative to the 34,000 or so
which currently exist and the low likely
needs of this uh District understand I'm
not me to make a comment 250 per
year sorry please uh
I'm I'm not taking further comments from
the public Gallery
but that was meant for um the notice of
those members of the public who might
have been misled by the reference to
thousands um that is not an
immediate requirement on us
um are you just uh wishing to indicate
Ley
Mr no I just was indicating that I'd
like to come back if I may want one
point Thank you go
ahead thank you um the only other point
that concerns me apart from policy
contradictions is the pepper
potting I heard and I must Adit I was
pleased to hear it that the developer is
making all the houses to the same
standard which is certainly a welcome
effect so I wonder if we could have
consider perhaps a more pepper potting
Arrangement because I don't think it's
healthy to have all the affordable
houses in one row I realize where there
plat there's not much you can do about
it but I'd like that to be considered
please Council
board thank you Jim um there there was
one issue that was bought up by members
and obviously it it it has uh troubled
me a little bit obvious ly with regard
to our core strategy and our initial
amount of 50 dwellings where we we now
have
7 um I would like some guidance from our
officers with regard you know to uh how
reasonable that excess is and will it
ever be considered an exception uh can I
have you know the arguments put you know
back to me as to uh as to why this is an
exception or
not it's not it's not exception to the
plan I mean the um the material the
principle of the of the res development
is set out in um in from point 6.1 to
6.8 and that goes through um why the
housing allocation um and why we we've
um we've got the Fig that we've got to
um as we just heard we've got Runnings
per Hector our minimum is 30 it's not
overdevelopment we're not high density
development we're quite um a good scale
we have got issues of um achieving some
of our housing Supply at the moment
because we've got stalling of some major
developments within the district um so
in in real terms there is a
consideration for this site um being
able to all um to provide additional
numbers it doesn't take development into
areas where where outside the um the
line of PR previously used land and the
um added bonuses to the land is bringing
forward forther open space um additional
connectivity and hopefully allotments um
if if the if the um capacity was um
significantly dense then obviously there
would be some considerations but it's a
very low low dense application before us
that I think seeks the the current umal
passing within this location chairman I
just come yeah yes sorry the word extion
was wrong um and I withdraw that it was
the wrong term um it was just wanting
clarification as to how that's been
arrived at because this question has
actually been raised by other members
thank
you wish to the
comments
chairman
iations thank you chairman chairman
let's look at this bullet point again
which just come off the board the
additional number of dwellings to be
provided on the
site is required to compensate for the
shortfall of dwellings that has had been
projected to be delivered within the
location identified the adopted core
strategy
that refers back to the AMR the AMR has
only just been delivered and there's no
shortfall at all in the district
therefore we be running against our own
policy document so I I can't support
this application based on the fact that
sufficient evidence to support the
requirement of page 50 of the allocation
sites is not get
them
okay do officers wish to reply to
that as set out in I mean set out in the
report in the report um paragraph 6.4
says the planning statements M explains
position land supply has been set out
monitoring statement um which confirms
the council that there was a 5e supply
within rer District planning statement
goes on to say that it is acknowledged
that in the report there's been delays
in bringing forward some allocated sites
um Four Road and SRI Mills and West
raing andrid sites and um and that Marin
also that the 5year supply can beic be
achieved bringing forward CL 20 21 sites
Bas of the information currently
available is consider that the 5e land
with r district with the last assessment
within the last 12 months the latest
2015 update of the 5D L will not be
available until early 2016 I is present
that some large sites have stalled and
will reach development State than
anticipated the additional number of D
of dwelling P for the sign are the
anticipated allocation modest and can
justly be considered against the
principle set out in policy se3 the
concept statement of policy se3 is clear
that it should not be applied too
stringently with regard to the total
number R numbers if this leads to site
moving forward and producing quality
outcome as this site falls in the
definition of previous developed site
this should be maximized their full
potential without jeopardizing design
and policy requirements such
maximization would would would reduce
the pressure to build on Green Belt
through any devel vment the development
would still provide a good level of
design therefore it's consider that the
development is acceptable the council
will not be justified in refusing
application the basis of add of the
resulting additional 25 dwellings
allocated area set out in SE 3 quy
allocation that is written in the in the
committee report and that's what would
stand in front of the council in terms
of any any decision
making i' not see any
further indications of those members to
speak um I think everybody has had Fair
crack of the whip on this
um in terms of uh uh the motion before
us uh it is for uh approval with a
number of additional conditions um I
wonder whether um officers could uh um
repa thees
those conditions have been added
um the issue with traffic caling we can
pick up with in regard to the condition
already set out condition 14 the
allotments we can carry forward um at
condition um 46 and also further with
further discussions the legal with
regards to
that yeah and then we'll just vary that
um the um at one that any change to the
um variation of how pen mix H20 will be
come back to the committee for
consideration which I think is is the
correct
position
chairman very briefly please all I'm
going to do is I propose and hope my
second it does that we pass this
application with the comments that been
passed through the discussion and has
been recorded by our new officers
tonight and I propose that we accept
it back briefly please very briefly I'll
just say that I I will be voting against
the motion if the motion for approval
Falls I will move a v motion for
deferral I think we're getting into deep
water here on the policy stage and I
think we need time to regroup and be
consider but certainly get it
right would members uh indicate those in
favor of the motion to
approve
against my
V because of the particular issue that
we've raised about the ALR and the fact
that we've now admitted we haven't got a
5e supply which is very dangerous thank
you thank you
right um item
seven been approved it has been
approved right apolog is for the delay
MERS of the
public um
it the uh 28 to 30 London Hill R to
consider an application to demolish an
existing Bungalow and construct three
detached five bedroom houses and form
two new vehicular
process please continue chairman this is
an application at 28-3 London Hil
GR
thank you the site location here shows
that the site consists of a detached
Bungalow we've also got an attached
house in this location as well the
attached Bungalow is on quite spacious
plot it's within the existing
residential area and whilst the site
itself is not located in the
conservation area conservation air
boundary is in close proximity on the
opposite side of the road here London
Hill is quite a busy classified road
leing to the top of R High Street so
it's quite prominent
location this site photograph just shows
the site in a little bit more context so
we can see the relationship with
neighboring properties we can see that
we've
gotor you can see that we've got some
detached hands either side of the site
and has directly opposite we've also got
a Woodland area which has got several
tree preservation orders on it we also
have two reserves with the actual
application site itself to the rear of
bungalow this also helps us show to some
extent the slope of the land so um as
many will know of in the r area London
Hill SLS up towards the High Street so
we're on quite varying land levels
here here we have the proposed layout so
the proposal was to demolish this
Bungalow no Works would Ur to the house
number 28 which would remain in this
location here and and construct three
detached
houses five bedroomed there would also
be two new accesses onto London hill
located here this would retain the
existing access and just modify it for
this existing for this proposed dwelling
here County highways do not OB to the
new accesses onto London Hill they the
proposed would have two off parking
spaces per property this would include a
driveway space and anal garage space the
garages do decrease slightly in 1 corner
to 6 M below the 7 m requirement but
this is still considered to provide a US
usable parking space it's only a very
small corner of the gar that produces
that quantity the 100 m Square Garden
area requirement is well exceeded here
per per property with regards to the
frontage widths um our requirement is
9.25 M and we're looking at around about
9 M here but it's still considered
sufficient um separation we've got hip
Roofing and visual gaps as well formed
through the land levels which generate a
degree of separation um between the
plots the technical housing stands the
Met met in relation to the total floor
space
requirements they storage spacing on one
Bas just below the requirements but
there is the capacity internally for
those to be adapted by condition to
enable those to
met this just shows an example what what
they would look like so we've got um
quite a contemporary looking Design One
plot would be handed we'd have hit
through and Dormers as
well okay County conservation officer
raises concern with the scale and design
does not object in principle to the
modern design but does consider the
proposal would have a negative impact on
the conservation area in its current
form officers do not consider this to be
the case the site is outside of the
conservation area and a modern design
has been approved for the Bungalow
directly opposite to be extended to form
a house of contemporary design board in
the conservation area which is something
that we need to Bear In Mind as a
consideration with this current
application
so here we have this the current Street
Scene so we can see nav properties here
and this is the house as well which is
within the application site you can see
just about see the Bungalow there this
also helped us show the graduation in in
London Hill and though we have an
example of what the street would look
like with properties in place so they
were follow the slope of London Hill the
scale and height within the streets in
is considered acceptable officers not
consider consider the proposal will
represent over
development with regards to impact on
Laing properties the property um which
is most likely to be impacted is number
32 which is located to the
Northwest the two story part of plot one
closest to number 32 finishes in line
with the rear elevation however a single
story element and a twostory part
further away from the boundary would
project deeper into the Garden area than
number 32 however I mean the impact on
this property is like be greater than
the existing Bungalow arrangements and
due to the land level differences but
it's not considered detrimental from the
extent of justify refusal of this
application the other impacted property
is number 28 which although within the
actual application site still requires
consideration the 445 degree angle would
be breached but number 28 is on a higher
land level therefore it's not considered
the overshadowing with result to that
particular property balconies are
proposed to all plots but 1.7 me to High
screens are proposed as well well to
each side of the balcony which would
prevent unacceptable
overlooking with regards to ecology
Servo work has been undertaken which has
shown evidence of bad activity within
the site mitigation is suggested that
this is accepted by the council's
ecologist um who just suggest a
condition be imposed to address that
with regards to trees we have two tree
preservation orders on the site um
however again the AR ARB culturist does
not raise issue um with that they should
not be impacted by development and
though works are proposed to them as
part of this
proposal it is considered that imp
planting should occur to the frontage of
the property of properties proposed and
this could be controlled sufficiently by
planning condition with regards to
archaeology there is archaeological
interest due to site's proximity to
railing Mountain Conservation Area and
work would be required which could be
controlled sufficiently by
condition with regards to drainage we
have land level differences and a
natural stream as identified by
residents within this area therefore
surface water drainage would be
important here and we can sufficiently
control that by condition to make sure
that we get something acceptable on the
site the recommendation is one of
approval subject to planning conditions
as listed within the officer
recommendation thank
you um we do not appear to have any
speakers scheduled um so I throw it open
to members um
I think you were
first
C coun
SMI yes thank you Mr chairman um in the
report the S County Council conservation
uh mentions that the erection of the
three houses would be the density which
would amount to over development would
be prejudicial to the compers cons
Conservation Area also mentioned that
the design also would have a negative
and intrusive impact on the conservation
area now this is mentioned in I think
paragraph 412 page
712 and uh the council uh tried to
combat that I think in uh paragraph 35
page 72 by saying that modern design has
been accepted in the conservation area
in two cases but I think this is
slightly disingenuous because I the um
's County Council conservation is not
talking about modern design it's talking
about the specific design um of these
homes and therefore I think um uh what
the report says is invalid to that
extent it does concern me about this
because I think London Hill is uh is
part of old grayy I think it's very
important uh in the conservation area
and I have concerns about it thank you
Mr
chair setto thank you
chairman with regards to the
archaeological survey uh I'm curious to
know if something significant is found
because of its close prop to go
M and was
to oped where the houses are would that
stop the house is from developing or
would it have to come back to us for
further discussion how would that
work we've had this issue on PO the
moment where they they dug they dug pits
and they found um significant finds what
they they do is two things they either
the fs or they actually just leave them
in situe if there development are going
to touch them so there's two op options
um it will not it will hold up the
development while they do further work
and the cost will be born by the
development itself not by anybody else
um so that's the position and that's
what's happen at at the moment is the
works taken there at the
moment what what I meant was if where
the house was built and that was to
cause damage to the
archeological um stuff found below would
what would the effect of
that I mean until until that survey was
taken and we can see what's under there
um there might there will be the options
are either they they remove those fines
or fines are retained in sit they don't
always they wouldn't always circumvent
ability to develop that that piece of
land yes yeah thank youman I could this
one in um read the report I wasn't clear
about a few items being on a slope you
got a lot of you've got a
big massive Garden there you've got
objections from the conservation officer
on the appearance I
thought presentation see what was there
um seeing that the design up on the
screen it's
contemporary I quite like it that's my
opinion um so I wouldn't be refusing on
those grounds
uh I let make one point though report it
quotes residents and one of them saying
it's a semi- rural area and you might
think it's a stone flad from the Town
Center there it's not semi rural but
actually I canum that point the other
side of the road you get the mount and
you've got a house with a vast Garden
incredible Garden of slope um on this
side you you've got wood you got B you
got lots of things there so it's
surprisingly it is a selling it has a
certain
a floor and fora aspect to it it is sem
R in that respect and I'm sorry to see
it developed but it's prob
inevitable so on the appearance I'm okay
with that um in terms of bulk I think
was a case we're looking at you know it
has to be developed I don't know why we
need to have three five bed properties
there um the bulk I think is
significant in terms of the parking
aspect we've got the parking standard
but two houses or two bedrooms or more
is
two parking spaces um and they provided
the bare minimum of two parking
spaces um although what the garages
slightly below that standard I haven't
measured it out to see how much
make the report does make mention of the
requirement for this is aing spes only
to say it's necessary because it's NE
Town Center well yes well having read
through tonight the the document
conserned um I'm not certain if this
this is any this is a particular urb
location Part Town Center There's No
Buses pass Ro here um and I think the
fact
that the houses are five bedrooms as
opposed to two bedrooms outweighs for
mitigation be near the Town Center I
think this is a case
for parking places which this case is
three of the parking space up to one um
so I think there's case they're cling
slightly too much in here and then if
they had a four three four BU Properties
or or five and two four whatever use a
bit more space a bit more parking a bit
less bul it would work better um that's
my than you thank
you K
Smith chairman um I haven't got quite
enough information in my mind to to make
a decision yet um I haven't been able to
see what the building line is to see it
in relation to the other properties
because these are fairly significant I
can see the line there but it's that
relationship with the other properties
that is
particular interest
made the the other thing is that um
Council black has been been talking
about parking um I do think thank you I
do think we are quite um quite
challenged to to two cars to a five
bedroom house they're absolutely going
to need those to two
spaces um on that particular slope of
London Hill cars parked on the slope and
the maneuvering of traffic around them
is problematical from a highway point of
view although s highways haven't really
recognized that but I I wonder whether
there we we still retain any ability to
put any uh restriction on the ability of
those garages at a future stage to be
converted or whether they have
um consent or of permitted development
rights to to do a conversion there I
think if possible I would like a
restriction on that um having seen that
building line they're they're not
particularly prominent of the um
adjoining properties so so I'll remove
that concern so um but but the issue
about the garage and that being used for
parking is important to me given the
specific location and the scale of the
property we can condition the garage not
to be converted into anything else a
garage so we can have that as additional
condition to protect that caring space
in areas like this we've got
car um do you do you require a proposed
amendment for that or is it just going
make if you are prepared to propose
it oh sorry cancel first
ccil thank you Mr chairman Mr chairman
I'm intrigued Behind these three houses
you've got this Woodland part then when
it comes up uh to the end then part of
it as it looks like it where you've got
where the D is on the edge of the the
map just beyond that that part is that
part of the garden of the first one
nearest the top of the hills and who is
um how much of that ground which is the
trees Etc is is that going to be divided
up equally between the three because
you've got that big area there it's part
of that green part that's there is that
off of the outway um uh with with the
open space is that part of
it that's the application site set up
with the applicant in front of you so
the red
L red L area is the is the application
site yeah but you what I'm looking at
that's the application site so there on
that part that's going to be three
Gardens right back to the end so that
can take a number of the trees and is
that an open space behind
it to the rear there's a triangular area
of Woodland which is subject tree
preservation order it's not within the
application site and it's not within the
ownership of the current application
site but the point is is that that land
that is opposite F wart school does it
back on to that
no so who then is responsible for the
trees Etc in that area it would be the
relevant landowner in that particular
area be responsible for the trees on
that
site Mr chairman I really am intrigued
by the Woodland part that I hope in part
that those trees all have tpos to keep
them officers have indicated that there
are tpos on all of those
trees any
significance councel Mr Mason and then
Council
SE thank you chairman I I must admit I
was also intrigued and um it was a very
good question one which I was certainly
going to come to but I I'm I TR get what
we were flicking around between the
various Street scen plans I was
beginning to think from what I could see
that they were three squeezed in as
opposed it looks it looks an
uncomfortable squeeze in relation to the
rest of the street scen and yet I can't
see see that that that picture there
that artist impression you know doesn't
impress me because you know that's just
inter interpolation of the houses into
the Gap but what's the rest of the rest
of the road look like I can't really get
a feel for it I kind of feel that's
wrong
come thank you very on that go back on
that other the one
before
please that one now you've got the the
bottom of the three houses and you've
got a very wide space there which
obviously is going to be part of their
Garden so is that going to them be
allowed to have car parking or that so
that actually it takes away um it gives
more car parking
area but for that particular house is
that part of it or is it just going to
be an overgrown grass bit it it
intrigues me I'm sorry
C that demonstrates the point I was
making you know they look squeezed in
and yet there seems to be space to move
the three further
apart I think what I say the root of
this is that it does appear that the
actual artist impression is just that
and it does not C in scale in scale to
the actual plan which is on that's the
one I Wasing also I think the plan we
showed before actually includes the
blank where the the existing houses as
well the house that sits below those
houses on the previous on that
supression isn't actually included so it
shows of land where actually it is the
house to the
um the southeast it
is the other diagram they've taken it
off that's correct yeah so that plan
that plan shows you the dentist compared
to everything else it shows you the true
true Arrangement how it sits with stre
scene rather than the impression which
shows you which takes off that just blow
it up slightly so we can see it a bit
clear yeah yeah good thank you very much
yeah that
one I
think
squee
I I Mr I can now see why the
conservation officer was concerned about
the impact on the
bul if the chairman may
have with your
permission um I just wonder whether it
could be indicated where the
conservation area begins or finishes the
case may be
thank
you to
proceed my point seems a little bit
Min I was simp going to point out with
visiting
paring they are within a 10minute walk
of two quite large Camp car
pars almost almost forgotten the
question um no it's it's just one of the
issues with regards to um water brainage
system
um I know at the bottom of London Hill
as it comes as it joins um London Road
as it goes through under the bridge uh a
lot of the drainage has has not been
maintained a lot of the drainage has not
actually been maintained uh in London
Road um and again it just concerns me
where we've got extra development going
in where there doesn't seem to be any
cence with regard to to drainage and I I
don't know if any anything that's been
looked at because again that comes down
to highways we talk about traffic but
also highways is responsible for a lot
of the the drainage and clearage which
they're not doing um which is extremely
frustrating um so I wonder what's going
to be uh in place with regard to the
media action uh it is a wee bit dense I
guess but it's
probably it it's it's really on the
cusp I'm looking at that as on the cusp
of of density um but but what's the
impact what's the impact with regard to
um surface water and things like that
that is envisioned within the
plane um there's a 17 that's that um
deals with um with the issues of service
water drainage um on the site and that
that has to be agreed um by the council
um prior to um any Works occurring on
site so that will be dealt with by
condition I see no further indications
um at the moment
uh we have a an amendment for um
preventing the um conversion of garage
space into additional living
accommodation anything other than
garages sorry anything than the gares CH
okay
um otherwise the
recommendation um is that plan
commission be
granted subject to the following
conditions um 1 through three that's on
page
725 and uh subsequent conditions um if
there are no
other wishing
wishing to change any of those
conditions um
I yes yes before you finish with all of
this um I want something put about the
um archaeological side of it because
although I know it sounds D but there
could be something in that area that has
an ancient well or something like that
on it and I wouldn't like to think that
something like that comes up when it's
looked at and it's just B this stuff and
just lost because I really like many
other people feel that it's so close to
the um uh the old uh castle that was
there and the stuff from that castle
went to Happ Happ castle that's history
but at the end of the day that was a
very important site all those years ago
and I think because this is so close and
it's where all the Woodland par is are
really want to know make certain that a
really proper archaological
uh look is done before any of it takes
place I'd like that as part of it set
out condition 22 yeah I know but I'm
making certain that that is really to me
the most important item to do with this
with this
development right
um I see I see
further yeah have you have you actually
moved the CL yet um I was moving from
the chair given that there was only one
um Amendment so far um I found this
meeting useful in the sense that the
where the committee is working
presentation is helping
decide my view starting off very
concerned and doubtful a bit happy later
on having found out that the the plan
that the artist impression was mely
about a misleading and looking at again
now I'm back being concerned about the
bulk I think it is overdevelopment is
too bulky on the edge of the
conservation area and I would like to
move refus on that places I think it's
as somebody it's on the C and I think
for me being so close to conservation
it's over the C second it I would I
would move refusal on those grounds I'll
second it and I see indications from
both Council M Mason then Council GL
that wish to second that um offices
um are you content to accept that or do
you wish to have the
reasons for considering it is over
development explain
please
I
mean the the application is um is is
acceptable in terms of how we have dealt
with the application and looking at the
the bulk of those buildings in Con in
the in the context of what is within
that within that local area um the issue
of development I don't think we can we
can remember the issue development and
an issue of bulk I don't think we will
be successful 32 is equally as bulky 29
is equally as bulky you look around the
site um and also you
are you move towards the southern part
of that that area you dealing with um
semi detached properties of of of of a
significant size um we wouldn't be able
to
substantiate based on over development
and bulk um
bation I'm in difficulty here because
we've got we've got a report from
conservation officer who recommends
refusal and I believe on balance that
that it is too bulky and and because of
the bulk of it besides that has knock on
effects in terms of the impa of neighbor
and also in terms of parking just a
little bit too much here um now if the
officers saying that this is on the bulk
this completely undefendable appeal and
I would have to
Ian we' end up paying cost and I
withdraw the motion if it is one we get
applications we get applications where
officers recommend approval and members
move refusal and it goes to appeal and
sometimes we win now I'm really you know
I don't want to give the offices a huge
amount of work if it's going to end up
paying costs but I just think bearing in
mind we have got conservation officer
recommending refusal but this is a
reasonable refusal to make yeah
C Mrs N thank you Mr chairman so you
could I just ask for some
clarification um we're talking here
about a recommendation for County
Council officer
refusal earlier we were talking about
eics County Council officers with
highways and with service draining we
were saying we have to defer to them and
yet now we're saying we don't have to so
I'm a little bit unclear here as to why
we have to defer to essics County
Council on some aspects but we can
ignore them on others so could I just
have a little bit of clarification on
that point thank you I mean in terms of
archaeology um Urban Design and um uh
and conservation information they are
purely an advisory part um which we we
actually pay for that function um and
with any any information we're given um
we as a as the local planning Authority
it forms part of that decision- making
process and obviously we we have to it
is a becomes a consideration we have to
look at and we we um we have a weight
and balance way of deing with
applications and you look at all
information that comes in together and
you make a balanced decision and in
terms of looking at the information
supplied by um um the application as a
whole the information from um the um
from Ence Cy Council as advisory which
we paid for um we would feel very
difficult in trying to in in trying to
protect that position at appeal and and
it's not a case of um the local planning
Authority shouldn't take a position that
if you are of the threat of costs being
a reason not to pursue a case to appeal
it is the case of you've got the right
materials to allow you to pursue and in
this case I don't think Mak information
we've got before is that it would be it
would be um in the interest of the
council to pursue this matter um through
to refusal and then if the applicant
decides to appeal um the um the outcome
of that appeal um may go um against the
council but it's not a cost issue with
this case but it's an advis Council
they're not like they are not the like
the highway Authority they're not in
control of this function we just don't
have our own offic to do this work if I
just I come back on that please Mr
chairman just come back in that so what
I understand from the officer is that
basically we have all the informations
we normally do and it's a matter of
really judgment individual judgment as
to the weight that we app to that advice
thank you um as for decision making um
the decision making process um in in the
council the offic and officer get the
application there and it goes through a
um approach where the officer makes a
recommendation that recommendation
checked by a um is validated by a team
leader it's further validated by myself
and then as with this case it will it
will go on on the on the weekly list so
it is a judgment call by um by in it's
um some Jud two officers another
appliation Jud three officers it is
judgment and that is the process that
the plan planners are trained in in
dealing with it's looking at information
and applying that to policies and also
to um other other material
considerations that we consider to be
for part the application and in this
case the advis comments from the um M
County Council um didn't didn't provide
enough Ste that the planning application
could beused this
instance thank you um the substantive
motion that we have before us is for
refusal um would those members inclined
to uh refuse please
indicate
okay those against refusal please
the motion for refusal is lost we
therefore consider the motion for
or motion from the chair
for
approval um with the condition as
amended for restriction of conversion of
um G faes
to S other uses
um those in favor of approval with that
additional condition please
show than you those
against motion the motion is for
approval thank you
everybody